Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich ach
wie immer
üblichen alten kleinen Ort
schreibenderweise schreibenderweise ja
immer noch vierter Band Philosophie
Geschichte das hört sich auch noch ewig
hinziehen weil das ja so ein riesiges
Projekt ist
Richard ich wollte heute mit dir über
den Club of Rome sprechen
vor 50 Jahren dieses berühmte Buch du
hast gerade die 70er Jahre erwähnt 72
das Ende des Wachstums und die Grenzen
des Wachstums Ja so heißt es eigentlich
richtig und es beginnt dieses Buch mit
einer Metapher die wie folgt geht man
denkt an einen Teich mit Lilien
und die Zahl dieser Linien verdoppelt
sich täglich
und innerhalb von 30 Tagen werden sie
das Wasser vollständig bedecken und
alles Leben darunter ersticken und die
Moral der Geschichte ist das ist das
spannende daran dass man noch am 29 Tag
also einen Tag vor der Katastrophe die
tödliche Gefahr nicht bemerkt weil der
Teich ja erst zur Hälfte überwachsen ist
aber dann ist es zu spät um zu handeln
das war sozusagen die Metapher dieses
dieses Berichts dieses Klapper from
Berichts und es gibt jetzt einen neuen
Bericht Club of Rome 50 Jahre danach
aber erstmal an Dich die Frage Richard
wie hast du das damals wahrgenommen was
was du da schon nee also
72 noch
beschäftigt sieben Jahre stimmt sieben
Jahre alt also das habe ich nicht
mitbekommen aber ich habe die die den
zweiten die zweite Welle mitbekommen und
zwar hat er 1977 Jimmy Carter eine
Studie in Auftrag gegeben Global 2000
also wie sieht die Welt im Jahr 2000 aus
die kamen 1980 raus und 1980 war ich 15
und da habe ich mich schon sehr für
Politik interessiert und diese Studie
hatte eine enorme Bedeutung für die
Gründung der Grünen und da stand ja
sinngemäß etwas ähnliches drin wie
damals in der dem Bericht des Club of
Rome nämlich dass wir mit wenn wir so
weiterleben wie bisher wir schon im Jahr
2000 in fürchterliche Zustände kommen
das war ein Bericht von über 1.400
Seiten ich weiß den gab es damals
irgendwie bei 2001 die hat natürlich
keiner gelesen 1400 Seiten aber man
wusste so ungefähr was drin steht und
man ärgerte sich darüber 1980 oder 81
war Dragon Präsident geworden in den USA
und dann ist der quasi in der Schublade
verschwunden und dann hat man da nicht
weitergemacht für Jimmy Carter war
damals grenzendes Wachstums Zukunft des
Wirtschaftens ökologisches Desaster ein
Thema gewesen aber wie wir alle wissen
war er kein besonders erfolgreich
Präsident und mit Dragon setzte dann
wieder die Rücken ja absolut genau aber
die Grenzen des Wachstums noch mal Club
of Rome ne der der Bericht von 72 das
war ein weltweiter Erfolg das hat damals
so den Nerv der Zeit getroffen ich habe
mir das noch mal angesehen weltweit 10
Millionen Mal verkauft über 30 Sprachen
übersetzt ein weltweiter Bestseller es
war in den 70er Jahren sozusagen fester
Bestandteil einer jeden West-Berliner WG
ja eine Pflichtlektüre für eine ganze
Generation das sozusagen die Frage was
passiert wenn wir so weitermachen was
passiert dann in 100 Jahren
und es muss man ja sagen ganz
interessant also du hast gerade kurz
angedeutet vieles ist daraus erwachsen
unter anderem die Gründung von
Greenpeace ja die die Gründung der
Grünen fällt in diese Zeit das war
sozusagen
ein ein Buch das ist eine ganze
Generation aufgerüttelt hat und das zum
ersten mal so ein ökologisches
Bewusstsein geschärft hat also ich das
hat ja noch ganz breiter Auswirkungen
also die beiden guten tieronkels des
Fernsehens ja also Bernhard Schimek und
Heinz Sielmann die schlugen in den 70er
Jahren plötzlich ganz andere Töne an ja
so vorher haben die einem einem versucht
irgendwie das Reich des buntspechtes
oder der dass das die die Wanderung in
der Serengeti zu erklären und nun endete
wirklich jeder Film damit auf die Drohne
Apokalypse hinzuweisen
das wurde richtig ein Thema also kein
Naturfilm seit Mitte der 70er Jahre
konnte enden ohne das Sehen voll die
Panflöte wimmerte ja und er hat erzählt
hat dass diese Paradiese ja alle wenn
wir so weitermachen
ja also das das setzte sich schon sehr
breit fest aber das ist jetzt am
einzelnen liegen sollte sein Verhalten
grundsätzlich zu ändern ich glaube das
hat er keine fünf Prozent der
Bevölkerung erreicht
ich meine wenn man sich das mal anschaut
es gibt ja sozusagen ein Vorläufer ich
weiß nicht du kennst wahrscheinlich
Thomas maltus oh ja weiß woher mein Ding
kennt ja sag mal der war ein zentraler
Anreger für Darwins Theorie für die
Evolution
beschäftigt dieser robert maultus war
ein ziemlicher tausendstler der war eine
sehr brutale type der war eigentlich
Fahrrad ne und arbeitete dann als
Nationalökonom und der hatte einen sehr
sehr fatalistisches Weltbild und auch
Menschenbild
1766 geboren ne ja 17 66 geboren und der
schreibt eben dieses Buch über die
zukünftige Bevölkerungsentwicklung exakt
und und redet von der bevölkerungsfalle
ja weil er als einer der ersten erkannt
hat muss man vielleicht einmal kurz
erklären dass sozusagen
Bevölkerungswachstum exponentiell geht
und hat sich also ausgerechnet
irgendwann mal sind wir einfach schlicht
zu viele und der Planet wird uns nicht
mehr ernähren können
wobei er sich für den Planeten muss man
ehrlich sagen noch nicht mal
interessiert hat ne also hat sich für
die Engländer interessiert also es
reicht jedenfalls
gegen die Armenfürsorge die ein brutales
Buch ja der hat gesagt wir dürfen jetzt
nicht dafür sorgen dass jetzt irgendwie
noch die Kinder der am medizinisch
betreut werden und so weiter denn was
ist denn das Ergebnis wir werden
irgendwann ja so viele sein dass wir
eine gigantische Hungerkatastrophe
kriegen deswegen ist es gut dass die
natürliche Selektion da kommt der
Begriff her die natürliche Selektion
dafür sorgt dass nur die Stärksten
überleben
und das sind natürlich im ersten hier
die privilegierten Schichten gewesen ja
und dass die Arbeiterschicht immer
wieder durch die natürliche Auslese
durch solchen durch Armut durch Hunger
dezimiert wird
also eigentlich ein ganz brutales Buch
und wenn wir heute sagen was war der
Fehler des Buches übrigens ist das Buch
heißt diskutiert worden das waren sehr
berühmtes Buch damals und es gab auch
gegenbücher also es gab gegen Bücher von
ja ist ja Sozialismus noch vor Marx in
den Kinderschuhen steckten steckte hat
William gottwyn einer der klügsten
Engländer aller Zeiten auch ein schlaues
Buch dagegen geschrieben und zwar was
hier nicht einkalkuliert ist ist der
Fortschritt in der Fortschritt in der
düngemittelproduktion zum Beispiel genau
und das zweite ist der soziale
Fortschritt das hat gottwind damals
schon gegen moltos geschrieben der kann
doch dazu führen dass die Leute nicht
mehr gezwungen sind 10 Kinder zu kriegen
sondern wenn es eine staatliche
Sozialfürsorge gibt kriegen die Leute ja
vielleicht weniger Kinder
insofern hat maultus die in den Fehler
gemacht aller Menschen die glauben man
könnte die Zukunft mathematisch sprechen
das und genau das ist deswegen fand ich
es so interessant mit dir heute mal
darüber zu sprechen weil was damit
einhergeht und du hast es ja eben schon
mal kurz an gejingles sozusagen wie ich
als alte Radio man sagen würde an dem
Punkt die Apokalypse dieser Horror diese
Horror Szenarien die dann die ganze Zeit
an die Wand gemalt werden so nach dem
Motto morgen aber wenn ich morgen dann
allerspätestens übermorgen gegen
Mitternacht geht die Welt unter und man
muss ja mal sagen glücklicherweise ist
nichts davon eingetreten ich meine
diesen Bericht des Club of Rome da steht
ja unter anderem drin das von da an
gezählt ne ein paar Jahrzehnte später
gibt es keinen Tropfen Öl mehr und das
übrigens gutes Timing auch ein Jahr
später war die Ölkrise ja richtig 73 ne
da ist man dann plötzlich tatsächlich
dieses Szenario vor Augen hatte und ich
kenne das noch aus meiner Jugend das
ständig die Rede davon war dass es bald
kein Öl mehr gibt das war so ein das
Szenario der 70er aber es gab ja Öl ne
das war ja eine künstliche Knappheit die
da hergestellt eine künstliche Knappheit
und was wird überhaupt nicht gesehen
wurde ist wie viel Ölfelder potenziell
noch erschlossen werden konnten
jetzt weiß ich nicht zu allmöglichen
Formen wie man in unglaublichen tiefen
Öl gewinnen kann und so weiter das heißt
also der Fehler den man gemacht hat bei
diesen Zukunftsprognosen ist man hat den
Status Quo einfach in die Zukunft
gerechnet und nicht gesehen wo Variablen
sind so das ist der Punkt also sie haben
damals ausgerechnet nach 20 Jahren das
war so die die Projektion wird keinen
tropfenöl mehr geben 72 20 Jahre weiter
hört 92 haben wir es langsam angefangen
richtig Gas zu geben ne er ist unser
seitens haben auch schlaue Leute
ausgerechnet des sehr interessant
seitdem diese Apokalypse erschienen ist
publiziert worden ist
ist das Doppelte an Öl gefordert worden
wie wie bis dahin ja übrigens fällt mir
ein bei der Kohle ist das ein bisschen
ähnliches hieß auch immer die Kohle
reicht nicht ewig richtig und warum ist
der Bergbau in Deutschland verschwunden
doch nicht weil keine Kohle mehr in der
Erde ist weil sich nicht mehr rentiert
hat exakt ja aber es gab viel mehr Kohle
als damals gedacht weißes interessant
weißt du was ich glaube ich glaube dass
dieser kriegsmangelgeneration ja die den
Club of Rome Bericht verfasst hat das
waren alles Leute die haben den Zweiten
Weltkrieg erlebt ja genau eine riesen
Angst davor hatten dass die Rohstoffe
versiegen
ja das hast du auch vielleicht
psychologisch erklärbar ist dass sie gar
nicht darüber nachgedacht haben auch uns
selbst wenn die versiegen was ist alles
für alternative Möglichkeiten in der
Energieerzeugung und so weitergeben
konnte also das ist sicher die
schwächste Seite des Berichts
du weißt doch nicht von wem die Idee
kommt und warum das Ding Klapper from
heißt
das tatsächlich in Rom organisiert
worden besprochen worden das war eine
Idee eines italienischen industriellen
Aurelio Patcher der mal Chef bei Fiat
war und einem Schotten Alexander King
einem Direktor der Pariser Organisation
der OECD die haben 68 so eine erste
Konferenz zur Zukunftsfragen in Rom
organisiert und dann 72 dann diesen
diesen berichtigen Grenzen des Wachstums
veröffentlicht der unter anderem ist
total interessant ich meine überleg mal
wie ironisch Grenzen des Wachstums unter
anderem von der Volkswagen Stiftung mit
800.000 Dollar gespon
in die Zukunft geklickt hat ja
ausgerechnet der Konzern der dann
Jahrzehnte später den den dieselskanal
Anlage hat
was für ein wahnsinne aber Budget war
wie gesagt an ein Mensch von viert aber
das Interessante ist diese diese Horror
Szenarien ja also nicht nur bei Öl alle
relevanten Rohstoffe hat man damals so
geschätzt 40 Jahre später gibt's die
nicht mehr ne Erdgas Kupfer Blei
Aluminium und so weiter also wenn diese
Vorhersagen eingetroffen wären dann
wären wir längste in einer Welt ohne
Erdgas ohne Kupfer ohne Blei Aluminium
und wenn man heute an an den Teufel an
die Wand malen würde und sagen würde wir
haben in 20 30 Jahren kein Öl mehr ja
oder oder keine Kohle würde das den
Menschen heute ja sehr viel weniger
Angst machen ist richtig weil wir sagen
müssen in der Zeit müssen wir sowieso
aus den fossilen Energieträgern
ausgeschrieben sein und brauchen sowieso
neue Energiequellen
aber damals konnte man sich das nicht
vorstellen obwohl man auch ich meine
auch in der damaligen Zeit wurde ja
schon geforscht erneuerbare Energien und
dergleichen aber
und obwohl man damals auch schon ahnte
das könnte was werden
hat man da nie so richtig drauf gesetzt
ja und die und die zentrale Aussage war
sozusagen spätestens im Jahre 2100 ist
quasi eine Katastrophe für die
Weltgesellschaft unvermeidbar das war
die Idee aber muss natürlich jetzt um
dem Club of Rome also sagen der Fehler
war sicherlich zu denken es gibt eine
Energieproblem was aber richtig war und
was daran so wichtig war ist dass sie
auf die Umweltverschmutzung hingewiesen
haben ja und tatsächlich das die Grenzen
des Wachstums einerseits darin liegen
sollten dass nicht genug
energieverfügung steht aber zum anderen
ist die Grenzen des Wachstums ja auch
deswegen ein wichtiges Thema werden
müssen wegen der ökologischen
Folgeschäden also den Klimawandel hatte
man 72 noch nicht auf der Rechnung aber
bei der von mir vorhin erwähnten Studie
Global 2000 von 1980 da taucht der
Klimawandel schon drin auf
82 ja nee 80 80 ist 80 80 1980 steht da
schon drin dass der Klimawandel ein
großes Problem werden könnte so und da
kommst Du doch jetzt eigentlich zu
diesem Punkt und deswegen hatte ich so
ein bisschen die Hoffnung dass wir heute
auch auf dieses Gleis abbiegen
die also wenn du diese Horrorszenarien
ja diese düsteren Prophezeiungen wenn du
die so hörst dann sagst okay komme ich
gehe heute Abend schlafen und stehe am
besten einfach nie wieder auf
tatsächlich aber erzählt diese
Geschichte und das ist das was ich für
mich daraus sehe auch die Geschichte
sozusagen einer Menschheit die dann am
Ende ähnlich wie Münchhausen vielleicht
dann doch immer wieder in der Lage sind
so wieder aus dem Sumpf rauszuziehen ja
wenn du überlegst die haben damals 72
eine Hungerkatastrophe für die gesamte
Menschheit prophezeit und haben dieses
dieses Bevölkerungswachstum einfach
exponentiell nach oben gerechnet ich
habe vor einiger Zeit eine Zahl gelesen
das hörst du jetzt auch zum Beispiel von
Menschen die sagen Afrika
Bevölkerungsexplosion allein einen Land
wie Nigeria wird in wenigen Jahrzehnten
so viele Menschen
in im Land haben wie die gesamte
Europäische Union ich habe wenn man sich
mal anfängt intensiver damit zu
beschäftigen große Zweifel daran dass
das so kommen wird ich glaube nämlich
nicht ich glaube aber viel lernfähiger
und und viel intelligenter und smarter
sind als genau solche apokalypsens
glauben was also die Demographen sagen
schon seit sehr langer Zeit dass sich
die Kurve des Bevölkerungswachstums
abflachen wird
also das das ist schon seit mach Ende
der 90er Jahre
ja die sagen so 11 bis 12 Milliarden
vielleicht und dann wird sich die
Menschheit nicht weiter vermehren
warum auch immer nicht also mich wundert
mich ja auch nicht ich habe ja vorhin
schon gesagt vorsicht vor mathematischen
Prognosen genau ja also ich glaube das
ist das ist eine Rechnung die man nicht
wirklich machen kann aber man zu viel
Variablen hat die man nicht ausrechnen
kann aber das Gute daran ist daran zu
glauben ist dass es andersrum ja auch
nicht sein muss also die die Menschheit
muss sich nicht unbegrenzt exponentiell
immer weiter vermehren also sind ja
keine keine lemming-kolonie oder so da
gibt es ja so viele Faktoren die eine
Rolle spielen und wir wissen ja
normalerweise ist der das Beste was
passieren kann es Wohlstandsentwicklung
war dann steigt die Bevölkerung nicht
mehr andererseits ist Wohlstand
Entwicklung das schlimmste was passieren
kann weil der ökologische Fußabdruck
immer größer wird und das ist uns
sozusagen
die beiden kl an denen man Vorbeigehen
es gibt noch eine Richard es gibt noch
eine und das habe ich habe ich selbst
viel gesehen wenn du durch Afrika reist
es ist die Bildung und Ausbildung von
Frauen
in dem Maß wie die die Bildung und
Ausbildung von Frauen zunimmt in dem Maß
kriegen sie dann auch weniger Kinder
das sind ganz ganz entscheidender Fakt
also bildung ist der Schlüssel zu
unglaublich vielem auch an dem Punkt was
ich war interessant an der dass sie sich
ja vollkommen recht was ich interessant
an der Diskussion finde ist da gibt es
einen wichtigen weltanschaulichen Faktor
drin
also die Konservativen die sagen seit
ewigen Zeiten also schon seit den 60er
Jahren ja also vor dem klapp offroom ja
die Menschheit wird mal zugrunde gehen
ein Überbevölkerung ja also vor allen
Dingen in der dritten Weltkriegen die
Leute zu viel Kinder übersehen dabei
gerne dass die Generation ihrer
Urgroßeltern auch acht bis zehn Kinder
im Durchschnitt hatte ja das war nämlich
als ist bereits wir armen waren war das
nochmal genau dasselbe aber die sagen
alles geht sowieso den Bach runter
gegenüber Bevölkerung und die Linken ja
sagen immer das ist öko-faschismus was
ihr da macht weil das größte Problem ist
nicht die Zahl der Menschen das größte
Problem ist der Lebensstandard in den
reichen Ländern weil wir ja pro Kopf
unendlich viel mehr Ressourcen
verbrauchen und unendlich mehr viel mehr
CO2 freisetzen als arme Menschen mit
vielen Kindern
und was mich daran nervt ist dass das
immer als entweder oder Diskussion also
nach dem Motto wer hat Schuld ja warum
können wir nicht beide Probleme ernst
nehmen ja und dieses zusammendenken von
beiden und dann solche Lösungen wie du
das gerade gesagt hast Bildung für
Frauen als zentraler Schlüssel ja
medizinische Versorgung auch auch eine
wichtige Sache richtig
Altersversicherung also in jedem Land in
dem es ein vernünftiges Rentensystem
gibt steigt auch die Zahl der Kinder
nicht in dem Ausmaß ja genau sonst tut
das das ist zum Beispiel so ein
interessanter Punkt darf ich mal aus dem
Nähkästchen plaudern Familien meines
Vaters meine große Eltern ne mein Vater
war der älteste von 14 Kindern
Bergbauernhof in Südtirol wir hatten das
war damals das Wort das war eine
beachtliche Zahl waren lange kalte
Winter aber
nichtsdestotrotz durchaus üblich also da
waren ganz ganz viele Familien mit
sieben acht neun zehn Kindern die zum
Teil unter schlimmsten Bedingungen
gelebt haben die zum Teil gehungert
haben und viele haben es auch nicht
überlebt und diese Kinder waren
sozusagen die Überlebensgarantie wie du
gerade sagtest die Lebensversicherung
auch quasi für die Eltern wenn sie
irgendwann mal alt sind das war die
Versicherung und ähnliches habe ich im
Hochland von Äthiopien zum Beispiel
beobachtet und es ist total interessant
zu sehen in dem Moment wo Bildung da ist
wo ein gewisser Wohlstand kommt das
konnte man zum Beispiel auch sehen bei
Menschen die aus der Türkei irgendwann
nach Deutschland gekommen sind die kam
mir an mir sehr vielen Kindern aber die
nachfolgenden Generationen heute heute
bringt die die eine eine
Türkin die hier in Deutschland lebt
bringt genauso viele Kinder zur Welt wie
deutsche Frauen auch ja
und das ist das ist interessant das
heißt diese diese Prognosen
funktionieren nicht die sind wahnsinnig
unsicher und deswegen gibt es da
sozusagen durchaus Anlass für Optimismus
darauf will ich hinaus ich hätte es gibt
einen neuen Bericht des Club of Romeo
man muss einmal noch mal vielleicht der
Vollständigkeit halber dazu sagen dieser
klapp of home wird auch häufig auch bei
uns in der Sendung und so zitiert ja die
Grenzen des Wachstums und so weiter und
es tut dann immer so als wäre das eine
präzise Prognose des Weltuntergangs
gewesen wenn wir so weitermachen so war
es nicht wenn du dich mit diesem Buch
mal beschäftigt dann siehst Du ich
glaube mit Hilfe von 12 relativ
bescheidenen Computern an die damals
versucht zu berechnen was könnten
denkbare Szenarien sein das war alles
ziemlich ungenau und ziemlich unkonkret
aber es hat eine Richtung gewesen und es
hat zu sagen gezeigt wir haben hier ein
Thema jetzt ist ein neuer Bericht
erschienen klappoform der tauchen diese
ganzen Themen natürlich zum ersten Mal
auch Klimaveränderung und so weiter
natürlich wieder auf
aber die sagen etwas was ich sehr
interessant fand die sagen
Bevölkerungswachstum Klimaveränderungen
die ganz in Frage der Ökologie und so
weiter ja die Frage ist Wachstums das
sind alles große Probleme die müssen wir
klären aber es gibt ein Problem das
steht über allem und das ist das in
Wahrheit viel größere Problem eigentlich
das größte Problem mit dem die
Menschheit gerade konfrontiert ist und
das ist folgendes Problem das Problem
nicht mehr sicher zwischen Fiction und
Fakten unterscheiden zu können
heißt wir können uns nicht mehr
sozusagen auf eine Wirklichkeit einigen
und das fand ich ein spannenden Gedanken
weil er auch in einem Buch von Klaus
brinkbäumer der mal Chefredakteur beim
Spiegel war ganz großartiger
Textschreiber aber auch text-chef da hat
lange in Amerika gelebt und es gibt ein
Buch in dem er genau das beschreibt wie
die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
heute eigentlich daran scheitern dass
sich die Bevölkerung nicht mehr auf eine
Wirklichkeit verständigen kann ja wenn
die eine Hälfte etwas ganz anderes
glaubt als die andere dann hast du als
Politiker ein echtes Problem weil dann
machst du immer Politik gegen mindestens
die Hälfte deiner eigenen Leute ja egal
was du entscheidest die andere Hälfte
wird immer was dagegen haben und sagen
so ist das doch gar nicht Schnee ist
doch gar nicht weiß sondern also ich
würde jetzt einfach aus philosophischer
Lust da mal den Brecher reinschlagen und
sagen das sind zwei verschiedene Dinge
also das eine ist sich auf eine
gemeinsame Wirklichkeit einigen und das
ist zwischen Fiktion und Fakten nicht
unterscheiden zu können das gehört gar
nicht zusammen sondern im Mittelalter im
Mittelalter konnten die Menschen
überhaupt nicht ja unterscheiden
zwischen Fiktion und überhaupt das war
ein alles dasselbe wie man lebt in einem
tausendjährigen Zeitabschnitt dann nach
dem Reich da kommt das Reich Gottes
irgendwann
die Eltern die älteren erinnern sich ja
genau
welcher Zeit man lebte nur dass man
irgendwie in den tausend Jahren das
Antichrists lebte auf die dann die
tausend Jahre alte Gottesherrschaft auf
Erden kommen sollte das war so ungefähr
die Vorstellung die Leute haben alle an
Adam und Eva geglaubt und ein Schöpfung
der Welt in sechs Tagen und so war das
war das Normalste von der Welt
und gleichzeitig konnte man sich weil
man so ein Quatsch geglaubt hat auf ein
gemeinsames Weltbild einigen
das heißt also über die längste Zeit und
das ist ja nicht nur typisches
Christentum das ist für alle durch
Religionen und Erzählungen solche
narrative zusammengehaltenen
Gesellschaften so also je mehr die Leute
bereit sind irgendwas zu glauben
[Musik]
eine gemeinsame Ideologie oder narrativ
so und dann kam die Aufklärung so und
dann hat man angefangen überhaupt
erstmal systematisch zwischen Fiktion
und Fakten zu unterscheiden
und dann präparierte sich so allmählich
ganz ganz langsam überlegt mal was ist
alles gibt noch an Aberglauben und und
was sieht was die Leute also sowieso
alles immer merkwürdiges geklaut haben
eigentlich so ein moderner Wissensstand
heraus der so sehr stark Fakten bezogen
war
das ist ja eine ganz ganz ganz neue
Errungenschaft und gerade in dem Moment
wo diese Zeit kommt kommt gleichzeitig
das fiktionsbedürfnis zurück die
sozialen Netzwerke entstehen und die
Leute haben wieder die Möglichkeit jeden
Scheiß zu glauben den sie glauben wollen
ja also wir tippen sozusagen auf dem
Höhepunkt der technischen Entwicklung ja
in gewisser Hinsicht in ein Mittelalter
zurück aber wo du in ein zersplittertes
Mittelalter das dass ich eben nicht mehr
auf eine Erzählung einigen kann sondern
jeder dreht seinen eigenen Film und das
ist meines Erachtens eine Folge der
individualisierten Gesellschaft du
kannst den Leuten nicht mehr Fiktionen
oder Religion vorsetzen sondern jeder
bastelt sich in seiner Hexenküche da
sein eigenes Elixier aber siehst du das
Richard jetzt mal kurz ernsthaft zu
werden siehst du das auch so als das
große Problem mit dem wir gerade
konfrontiert sind also
Klimawandel ehrlich gesagt für das
größte Problem aber das hier ein großes
Problem damit haben diese Zersplitterung
oder fragmentarisierung der
Öffentlichkeit also man muss das auch
mal von der positiven Seite sehen noch
nie hatten Menschen so viele
Möglichkeiten sich zu informieren aber
mit den Möglichkeiten sich zu
informieren steigen natürlich auch die
Möglichkeiten sich zu desinformieren
und das was für sich selbst richtig
entscheiden zu können setzt er eine sehr
sehr hohe geschulte und sehr
reflektierte Urteilsfähigkeit voraus und
das Problem scheint mir ein bisschen zu
sein dass für viele Menschen das
wichtigste nicht ist was wirklich die
Wahrheit ist sondern recht zu haben und
das sind zwei verschiedene Dinge
und wenn der Weg zum Recht haben sehr
schnell geht indem man einfach was liest
was einem gefällt
dann entstehen das war übrigens früher
auch so ne also an den Stammtischen der
Republik war das reine
wahrheitsinteresse früher ja auch nicht
besonders hoch und heute sind die
sozialen Medien allen voran Twitter so
was wie ein virtueller Stammtisch indem
man das was quasi an Stammtischen
gedacht und rausgehauen wird quasi
öffentlich sichtbar macht
bestimmt wobei es auch häufig eine tolle
Quelle für viele Dinge ist weiß ich
Leute an Zusammenhänge erinnern an
Zitate erinnern an Fotos
die größte Bedeutung von Twitter ist
immer ein Diktaturen also soziale
Netzwerke haben ihre große chirurgische
Bedeutung in Ländern in denen es eine
totalreglementierte Öffentlichkeit gibt
da sind sie wichtig und unverzichten ich
habe mit neulich mit Dimitri glukowski
darüber gesprochen den du wahrscheinlich
kennst großer russischer Science-Fiction
Autor der Metro 2033 unter anderem
geschrieben hat wird und das heute liest
es Wahnsinn die Welt nach Nuklearschlag
wie sich Menschen in die Metro in Moskau
und so weiter zurückziehen der mir sagte
ja stimmt 80 Millionen Russen Nutzen im
Moment YouTube und das ist der Grund
warum die das nicht einfach abschalten
können da gibt es sozusagen eine Ecke
die die nicht kontrolliert kriegen weil
zwar nur 10 bis 15 Millionen das
politisch nutzen aber der Rest nutzt es
für Entertainment und wenn sie den
Leuten in diesem mühsamen Alltag in
diesem mühsamen russischen Alltag
sein so 200 Dollar
Durchschnittseinkommen auch noch Youtube
also die das Entertainment wegnehmen
dann kriegen sie ein Problem das ist
sehr interessant er mir oder du merkst
okay da gibt es Grenzen ja auch für für
so eine Diktatur da kann die nicht
einfach
jederzeit eingreifen und und den den
Hahn ausmachen ich würde nicht aber ich
finde das
das ist das interessantes ist quasi der
Preis der Freiheit und es ist der Preis
des ungehinderten Zugangs zu
Informationen jeglich Couleur die ja
jetzt nicht auf ihre Wahrhaftigkeit
überprüft werden der Preis ist dass die
Gesellschaft dann kein gemeinsamen Film
mehr dreht
und da stellt sich die schwierige Frage
wie reagiert man ein Land in dem das so
ist dass das was ich voll meinte genau
da sind wir wieder bei Michael
Kretschmer
der genau das in seinem Land zu hat ja
in Sachsen ja genauso und das und das
sieht man ihm richtig an wie sie ihn da
zerreißt und da ein einen großen Spagat
machen muss genau und dem immer wieder
versucht und auch manchmal
zerreißt ihn einfach schlicht und
ergreifend man sieht es ihm richtig an
nochmal zurück zum klapperschrauben
Richard und oder mal zu ganz
grundsätzlichen Frage ich bin in dem
Zusammenhang auf etwas sehr
Interessantes gestoßen ich du weißt das
bestimmt mir war das völlig unklar
Ludwig Erhard ich meine das ist
sozusagen unser ja kapitalistischer
Superheld ja aber soziale
der Marktwirtschaft ja genau politische
Vater der sozialen Marktwirtschaft also
der hielt von dauerhaft ungebremstem
Wachstum offenbar nicht viel das ist
richtig also damit habe ich mich viel
beschäftigt genau in diesem Buch ist
berühmte Buch Wohlstand für alle ja da
führt er aus dass Wachstum zwar für ihn
eine historische Notwendigkeit ist die
aber und das interessant in Zukunft in
einer wie auch immer definierten
ferneren Zukunft auch wieder entfallen
könnte ja das heißt so und was wir doch
gerade erleben ist was also Ludwig
Erhards Lehrmeister ja also die Väter
der sogenannten Freiburger Schule ja die
einen Kapitalismus mit möglichst
menschlichen Gesicht erfinden wollten
die haben sozusagen gesagt die
Errungenschaften des Sozialismus bauen
wir in den Kapitalismus ein soziale
Marktwirtschaft und einer dieser Väter
Wilhelm Röpke der wandelte sich noch zu
Lebzeiten Ende der 50er Jahre in ein
Pessimisten
und zwar diese Generation hatte vor
folgendem Angst der hat ein Buch
geschrieben das heißt jenseits von
Angebot und Nachfrage
und die Angst war dass wenn die Leute
sich nur auf das Materielle fokussieren
in einer wachstumsgesellschaft
genau das passieren könnte worüber wir
gerade gesprochen haben dass das auf
Kosten sehr Werte der geteilten Werte
und des sozialen Kids geht
also diese Leute hatten Angst dass das
zu viel Wohlstand die Menschen im
ethischen und im materiellen Sinne
maßlos macht und das war in einer der
lieblingssätze von Ludwig Erhard als
Kanzler dass er immer zur Mars halten
aufgehend genauso die Angst eine
Gesellschaft verliert Mitte und maß wenn
sie immer nur an das Meer denkt
das ist quasi ein klassischer Topos der
konservativen
interessant oder absolut und ich
interessant ist auch zum Beispiel das
ist diese Gedanke einer
Postwachstumsgesellschaft ne dass der
ururalt also ich will jetzt nicht
zurückgehen auf diese Wirtschaftsmodelle
von Platon Aristoteles und so die
wollten auch
ja also der angelsächsische Philosoph
des 19 Jahrhunderts der Vater des
Liberalismus der träumte von einem von
ihm sogenannten stationären Zustand
also von einem Zustand wo eine
Wirtschaft nicht mehr wachsen muss weil
alle auch genug haben und die trotzdem
funktioniert
das war sein großer Traum und abgesehen
davon gehört er zu den Vätern der
Ökologie indem er sich eigentlich ganz
süßes Bild wenn man sich das heute
vorstellt sagt Großbritannien Maja
ursprünglich komplett bewaldet so und
dann wurde das Wald der Wald abgeholzt
zunächst weil die Römer da ihre Schiffe
gebaut haben aber dann für die
Landwirtschaft und natürlich ist das gut
den Wald abzuholzen Felder anzulegen um
die Bevölkerung zu ernähren und das kann
man ja immer weiter steigern aber wie
wird England mal aussehen wenn da kein
Baum mehr steht das ist ja der Punkt und
wir reden hier aus dem Jahr 1848 so und
wie sieht England heute aus ja also das
ist ja weitgehend eingetreten also die
Waldgebiete sind deutlich überschaubar
heute ja abgesehen davon dass die
Landwirtschaft heute nicht mehr der
wichtigste Wirtschaftszweig ist genau
dass er eigentlich ganz einfacher und
logischer und völlig konsistenter
Gedanke ja dass in einer endlichen Welt
in einer Welt vollendlicher Ressourcen
das Wachstum nicht unendlich weitergehen
kann ja dass du eigentlich ganz
einfacher Gedanke oder nicht ja das sind
ganz einfacher Gedanke und das ist ein
Gedanke den konservativ Teilen ich hatte
ja gerade geredet von Ludwig Erhard den
liberale Teilen ich denke an meinen halt
Miegel ja der liberale
liberalkonservativ ist der Kurt
Biedenkopf ganz eng mit ihm
zusammengearbeitet hat ja der also schon
vor langer Zeit am Buch geschrieben hat
das exit heißt ja und jetzt nicht aus
der Perspektive irgendeines
radikalökologen
ja sondern aus der Perspektive eines
liberalkonservativen der eben auch genau
das gleiche gesagt hat es gibt kein
unendliches Wachstum in einer endlichen
Welt
so jetzt haben wir das große Problem wir
können uns aber eine Gesellschaft ohne
materielles Wachstum nicht vorstellen
ja gar nicht ja ist richtig also mich
überlege noch erstellen wir uns mal vor
es gebe jetzt zehn Jahre lang kein
Wirtschaftswachstum in Deutschland so
wie unsere Wirtschaft gegenwärtig
organisiert wird wäre das eine totale
Katastrophe ja und freuen würden sich
all die Länder die ein hohes
Wirtschaftswachstum haben weil die dann
mehr Anteile auf dem Weltmarkt erobern
genau hast du das mal dekliniert was das
wirklich bedeuten würde ich ich habe
mich das erste Mal intensiv damit
beschäftigt als ich das letzte Buch von
Ulrike Herrmann gelesen habe Ulrike
Herrmann kennst du
taz Autorin die ich unheimlich mag quasi
so eine so eine die ist immer im
kampfeslaune um es mal sozusagen beim
letzten Mal an Frank Thelen aus ich weiß
wobei das mit Frank Thelen war nicht
ganz fair nee hat natürlich Recht hat
natürlich recht ich habe danach noch mal
mich ein bisschen mit Inflation und so
weiter die beiden sind geraten ne ja
genau
die Wahrheit liegt bei beiden so ja wenn
man viel viel viel Geld druckt dann hat
man irgendwann Inflation das war die
These von jedenfalls wenn man viel viel
Geld druckt und die Wirtschaftsleistung
dem nicht entspricht so so das ist die
klassische alte Milton Friedman Theorie
der Inflation die nicht ausreicht um
Inflation zu erklären die aber nicht
falsch ist und sie hat als Hauptargument
gebracht was im Augenblick der große
Inflationstreiber ist nämlich dass die
Energiepreise sich so stark erhöhen und
damit die Produktion teurer wird aber
man muss ganz ehrlich sagen also nur
weil das mit den Energiepreisen stimmt
ist das mit der Vermehrung der Geldmenge
nicht falsch exakt dass der Punkt
vielleicht sollten wir da noch mal
hinterher gehen dieses Thema ist
spannend treibt gerade auch so viele um
aber was was ich dir eigentlich sagen
wollte in diesem Buch
sagt Ulrike Herrmann also das Buch hat
die zentrale These wir müssen irgendwann
das wird nicht weitergehen die die die
Idee sozusagen die die neue fantastische
Idee da gibt es dann dieses grüne
Wachstum
und dann fliegen wir alles sozusagen
emissionsfrei weiter um die Welt und so
weiter und eigentlich ändert sich gar
nichts von der können wir uns so die
These von Ulrike Herrmann ein für alle
Mal und komplett hoch verabschieden und
sie sagt machten Gedankenspiels weil ich
total spannend wenn wir die Wirtschaft
um 50 Prozent reduzieren würden dann
wären wir heute so reich wie die
Westdeutschen
und sie sagt das ist total interessant
ist da wurde Argentinien
Fußballweltmeister da kam der erste Teil
von Star Wars in die Kinos und so weiter
und sie sagt 78 mal ganz kurz waren
gutes Leben eigentlich haben wir gelebt
wie heute es gab keine flugmangos es gab
keine Erdbeeren im Winter aber
eigentlich war sonst alles wie heute man
ist auch nicht als Betriebsausflug mal
für zwei Tage nach Mallorca geflogen
sondern eher für drei Wochen nach
Italien an Strand gefahren ist
vielleicht sogar besser es war ein
bisschen entschleunigter aber es war
nicht so dass die Leute schlecht gelebt
hät und trotzdem weißt du dass die
Wirtschaft um 50% kleiner war das finde
ich interessant das ist interessant aber
das Problem ist dass das ist ein schönes
Szenario sich das auszumalen und dann
begreift man eines der entscheidende
Grund warum die Wirtschaft wächst ist
nicht weil die Menschen das glauben dass
es dann für alle ein besseres Leben gibt
das ist gar nicht das Motiv das Motiv
ist dass unser
wirtschaftssystemisch auf Wachstum
angelegt ist und das Problem ist dass
ein einzelner Staat ja nicht ausbrechen
kann also ich mal abgesehen davon dass
Regierung nicht beschließen können dass
wir kein Wirtschaftswachstum mehr haben
das wird ja sowieso sowieso nicht
funktionieren aber es wäre einfach wenn
wir kein Wirtschaftswachstum hätten
würden andere Länder in die Lücke
vorstoßen
und man kann auch nicht auf europäischer
Ebene festlegen dass die die
Volkswirtschaft nicht mehr wachsen
sollen das heißt also ein irgendein
realistisches Szenario und ich habe das
Buch von Ulrike Hammer nicht gelesen
aber wenn das da drin steht würde ich
mich ja sehr freuen wirklich mal erklärt
wie eine
Postwachstumsgesellschaft ja
funktioniert ich habe Beispiele für dich
also sie sagt zum Beispiel wenn es mal
wirklich durchdenkt und sagst okay das
können wir so nicht weitermachen
Stichwort auch CO2 das bedeutet zum
Beispiel dass auch so
energieintensive Produkte wie Zement ja
das gibt es da nicht mehr Beton weil es
einfach viel zu viel CO2 produziert das
bedeutet der Traum vom Eigenheim ist
dann eigentlich hinüber übrigens auch
deswegen weil wir nicht wie bisher jeden
Tag 30 Hektar rund um Boden einfach
planieren können das ist das was
passiert okay
jetzt stellen wir uns das mal vor kein
Zement kein Beton mehr
bekanntermaßen muss Deutschland in den
nächsten 20 Jahren so quasi sämtliche
Autobahnbrücken neu machen
aus ziegelsteinmauern ja ist die Frage
eher Holz also sie sagt schon unendlich
teuer genau sie sagt der Traum von vom
Eigenheim wäre das alles nur eine
Fiktion aber der Traum vom Eigenheim
wäre dann hinüber sie geht noch weiter
und sagt auch fliegen wenn wir
Klimaschutz ernst nehmen dann muss die
Menschheit am Boden bleiben ist dann
vorbei dann müssen auch die Güter am
Boden bleiben weil erheblicher Teil ist
ja auch Frachtverkehr ja genau also die
flugmangos über die wir gesprochen haben
und so auf die sie am Ende nicht ankommt
aber das wäre natürlich also wenn alle
Produkte die bei uns irgendwo
eingeflogen werden wenn die also nicht
mehr eingeflogen werden könnten das wäre
schon ein ganz ganz erheblicher
Unterschied zumal man denke auch an all
die Teile Schlüsseltechnologien die in
der industriellen Produktion benötigt
werden also ich will gar nicht wissen
was dann alles nicht mehr herstellbar ja
sind in Deutschland arbeiten direkt oder
indirekt ungefähr 850.000 Menschen in
der Flugindustrie die haben dann ein
Problem
exakt konsequenter Klimaschutz würde
nicht nur die Industrie verändern das
würde auch zum Beispiel viele
Dienstleistungen verändern es wäre zum
Beispiel überflüssig sagt sie Werbung zu
machen wenn Güter sowieso knapp sind ja
und sowieso garantiert ein Käufer
gefunden wird dann brauchst du auch
keine Werbung mehr zu machen das heißt
PR-Agenturen es muss kein Bedarf ist
gekackt werden genau Werbegrafiker die
hätten nichts mehr zu tun unklar wäre
immer ausgerechnet wie viel Millionen
Arbeitslose sie glaubt die dann
entstehen und was die dann machen das
habe ich ehrlich gesagt so als absolute
Zahl jetzt nicht im Kopf ich fand nur
dieses Szenarien so irre wenn du das mal
wirklich deklinierst also auch zum
Beispiel Anzeigen ich meine das wichtige
Geschäft für Zeitungen aber auch für
Google also für Alphabet und für Meta ja
Facebook die großen Plattformen die sich
so viele zeigen teilen und ein
unglaubliche Gewinne damit erzählen das
wäre obsolet weißt du was noch obsolet
wäre fand ich auch total interessant
Lebensversicherungen das Prinzip
monatlich eine kleine Prämie einzuzahlen
damit am Ende dann ein ordentlicher
Überschuss rauskommt das gibt es da
nicht mehr weil nicht mehr wächst ja
wenn es kein Wachstum mehr gibt dann
gibt es auch diesen Überschuss nicht
mehr also zu so meinst das sozusagen die
private Lebensversicherung gerne
Überschüsse generieren kann genau weil
die Börsen würden aufgebaut sind zum
Beispiel genau das ist aufgebaut auf
Wachstum und dann würden auch Banken
wahrscheinlich zusammenbrechen weil auch
die sind aufgebaut Wachstum ja jetzt
jetzt beschreibt sie das als ein
positiven Zustand oder als als als
wirtschaftsapokalypse also sie ist es
kannst du dir aussuchen also ich sag mal
sie sagt was würde dann werden aus dem
Großraum Frankfurt zum Beispiel ja was
würde übrig bleiben vom DAX
die Papiere von Airbus und und MTU und
so weiter wenn es keine Flüge mehr gäbe
oder Finanzamt passieren würde wer die
absolute Mehrheit der AFD die Münchner
rückt zum Beispiel die Deutsche Bank die
Allianz wird sie alle noch geben ja okay
aber es ist das alles nicht mehr gibt
aber wenn das alles zur Arbeitslosigkeit
führt und man bräuchte dann ein ganz
neuen Plan ja also was arbeitet noch an
die wird arbeitsverteilt wie wird
volkswohlstand erwirtschaftet der ja
nicht fertig in der Schublade liegt also
ich glaube dass die AFD mit der These in
Deutschland schafft sich ab die absolute
Mehrheit in Deutschland bekäme
das glaube ich wäre die Folge eines
solchen Szenarios ja ich fand es
spannend an dem Buch ja da kann man kann
man sagen okay ist verrückt geworden was
erzählt ihr da und so weiter ja diese
Untergangsszenarien diese
Horrorszenarien aber so ist es nicht
gemeint ich fand es einfach mal
interessant mal zu verstehen warum und
das kapierst du wenn du das liest warum
wir so sehr
systemisch wie du vorhin auch gesagt
hast darauf angewiesen sind dass wir
wachsen wachsen
ganz ganz viel gar nicht mehr
funktioniert die private auch die
gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung ist auf
Wachstum angewiesen richtig also diese
ganze Vorstellung dass wir
jahrzehntelang ja eine Rente oder eine
Pension oder sowas ausbezahlt bekommen
wäre nicht mehr möglich wenn die
Wirtschaft nicht wächst
richtig und ich sehe jetzt so also ich
mich würde wünschen ich würde mir
wünschen vielleicht macht Ulrike
Herrmann das als nächstes mal so einen
kleinen praktischen Fahrplan in so ein
bis zwei Jahres Schritten wie das
eingeläutet werden soll dass es sich
wirklich segensreiche auswirkt ich finde
ja das ist nicht ihr Job ich ich ich
finde es ich finde es einfach nur
interessant und das ist ihr Job auch
heißt Journalistin einfach mal die
Analyse zu machen und zu gucken und
sagen was wäre wenn das ist die Analyse
so funktioniert unsere Welt und
tatsächlich funktioniert sie auch
genauso und die Frage die daraus
resultiert ist das wird dir ja klar das
ist für gigantische Herausforderung vor
der wir stehen deswegen traut sich das
auch politisch keiner in irgendeiner
Form so anzupacken so konsequent
deswegen träumen auch grüne auch unser
Anton Hofreiter zum Beispiel davon wie
toll es ist dann emissionsfrei um die
Welt zu fliegen und so weiter ja es
traut sich keiner den Leuten zu sagen
aber die Frage bleibt und die Frage wird
immer drängender Frage finde ich auch
wichtig kritisiere die Grünen ja auch
dafür dafür dass sie im Grunde genommen
die Position der FDP übernommen haben
wir lösen alle großen Umweltfragen über
Technik so und jetzt würde ich natürlich
sagen so einfach ist das nicht weil
Technik verändert ja die Gewohnheiten im
Leben ganz stark also dadurch dass die
Autos in die Städte kam wurde das Leben
für dich anders als es vorher gewesen
ist die Menschen haben sich angepasst du
hast ja vorhin von der
Anpassungsfähigkeit genau das heißt also
technische Herausforderungen sorgen
immer dafür dass Menschen sich an
Gegebenheiten anpassen dass sich der
Lebensrhythmus verändert vielleicht auch
Berufe entstehen die es vorher nicht gab
andere aussterben und so genau das heißt
Technik geht immer mit der Veränderung
von Lebensgewohnheiten einher warum kann
man den Leuten nicht sagen eure
Lebensgewohnheit müsst ihr sowieso
verändern ob jetzt mit großen
technischen Neuerungen oder ohne wir
haben tatsächlich gar nicht die
Alternative auf der einen Seite zu sagen
wir lösen alles mit Technik und auf der
anderen Seite zu lösen wir verzichten
jetzt und führen einfach ein anderes
Leben sondern wir müssen sehen dass
diese beiden Dinge untrennbar
zusammengehören aber es ist leider so
dass die Grünen seit einiger Zeit und
das habe ich ja schon oft kritisiert den
Leuten nicht mehr zumuten wollen dass
sie ihr Verhalten größer im größeren
Ziel ändern wollen und das wäre sehr
wichtig dass wieder zurückzugewinnen und
nicht einfach nur zu sagen wir ändern
alle wir lösen alle Probleme mit Technik
wir lösen viele Probleme mit Technik ich
bin ein großer Freund
davon dass wir mit innovativer Technik
ökologische Probleme lösen aber wir
sollten uns nicht einbilden dass wir nur
mit innovativer Technik allein und ohne
eine Veränderung unserer
Lebensgewohnheiten diese Probleme lösen
können das ist irreführend ist das nicht
interessant Richard überlege ich gerade
was da psychologisch passiert ich meine
wenn man ganz ehrlich sind wir alle wenn
wir nachts mal nicht schlafen können
oder im stillen Kämmerlein wir wissen
das doch alle
wir wissen doch alle dass es so nicht
weitergehen wird und wir wissen dass wir
irgendwie anders weitermachen müssen
dass wir andere Wege finden müssen und
ich glaube noch nicht mal dass das
schlecht sein wird ich glaube dass wir
gute Lösungen für viele viele Dinge
finden werden die Frage ist ich glaube
das auch Markus die ganze Frage geht
doch nur darum werden wir das
rechtzeitig schaffen und werden wir die
guten Ideen situativ politisch
durchsetzen können oder sind unsere
Politiker immer gerade mit anderen
Dingen beschäftigt warum diese wirklich
großen wichtigen Fragen am Ende dann
zweitrangig werden ich glaube das ist
die offene Frage und da wage ich keine
Prognose
also ich glaube dass das Bewusstsein der
Menschen weiter ist als die Politik das
ist kein Vorwurf an die Politik ich
glaube auch dass das Bewusstsein in der
Wirtschaft auch aus Eigeninteresse im
Hinblick auf Nachhaltigkeit nicht bei
jedem aber bei vielen viel
fortgeschrittener ist als das was die
Politik glaubt im Augenblick durchsetzen
zu können ich glaube das ist die
Diskrepanz ja ich habe ich habe was ich
ganz es gibt noch zum Schluss noch ein
interessanten Gedanken eines Mannes
denen du kennst besser kennst an gewisse
Harald Welzer Welser hat dieser Tage
oder ist schon ein bisschen her was
interessantes geäußert der sagte da gibt
es immer sozusagen den die Sehnsucht und
da kommst Du ganz schnell wieder zu auch
zu diesen ganzen
autokratischen Tendenzen die so gibt ja
die Sehnsucht nach starken Anführern da
gibt es sozusagen die Sehnsucht nach
einem weltenplan einer muss doch jetzt
mal kommen muss einen großen Plan haben
um mal sagen wie es läuft
so und da siehst du auch wie zum
Beispiel das ist so ein Vorwurf den
nicht er aber den kann man finde ich
teilweise der jüngeren Generation machen
dieses radikale das da drin ist ne
dieses es gibt es gibt Gedanken auch zum
Beispiel von Leuten die sagen wir müssen
den Leuten jetzt Ansagen es gibt nur
noch ein Kind pro Familie Ende aus
Feierabend weil es geht so nicht weiter
das heißt diese diese seltsamen
autokratischen Tendenzen die da so drin
sind die die machen mir Sorge weil das
das ist genau die Richtung in die es
geht diese radikalen Forderungen führen
dann genau zu solchen Geschichten und
das und das ist das ist nicht die Lösung
einfach da rein zu sagen man muss
radikal denken ja so wie Ulrike Herrmann
dass er in gewisser Hinsicht auch
gemacht hat also den Mut haben radikal
zu denken um dann pragmatisch zu handeln
dass die Angst die ich habe ist wenn wir
und das ist vielleicht auch das was
Harald Welser sagen möchte wenn wir
nicht schnell genug sind ja dann werden
die Leute mit dem großen Welten planen
also das sind die Leute mit
autokratischer Gewalt
die werden dann die Dinge machen müssen
also die Angst besteht darin wenn wir
als demokratisch liberale Gesellschaft
nicht schnell genug sind und dann mit
den Folgen des Klimawandels konfrontiert
sind eine der wesentlichen folgen wird
natürlich massenmigrationen aus Afrika
sein in einem Maßstab wie wir sie bisher
überhaupt noch nicht gesehen haben weil
die ganzen semiariden Gebiete in denen
100 Millionen Menschen leben in Afrika
nicht bewohnbar sein werden oder nicht
mehr fruchtbar genug wenn so etwas
eintritt oder die Meeresspiegel steigen
und Folge der der Polkappenschmelze und
so also wenn das alles eintritt dann
sind wir ein Land in einem ökologischen
mega-krisenmodus
und dieses Land wird dann diktatorisch
regiert werden mit Notverordnungen mit
erlassen und was weiß ich was und zwar
egal ob von links rechts oder aus der
Mitte und wenn man das verhindern will
dann muss man in der Demokratie in der
wir leben und die wie ich so gerne
bewahren möchte schnell genug sein und
nicht in eine Notsituation zu kommen in
dem total diese Probleme gar nicht mehr
demokratisch das heißt durch Austausch
Interessensabwägung Diskussion gelöst
werden können das ist so ein bisschen
die Angst die ich habe dass wir nicht
schnell genug sind total interessant
weißt du mit wem du ganz schnell noch
zum Schluss mit wem du diese Angst
teilst mit Thomas de Maizière ja den
triffst du gelegentlich offensichtlich
genau und das wahnsinnig interessanter
Mann finde ich
Spitzname die Büroklammer ein
interessanter Mann weil er im besten
Sinne einen Beamter ein Verwalter ist
der erzählt das auch sind wir mal
gelesen er sagt er hatte immer Lust an
der Spitze einer großen Behörde zu
stehen weil die eben im zwei mehr zu
sagen hat als die Politik weil ich total
interessant hat aber dann seinen Weg in
die Politik gefunden und ist ja jemand
der fast jedes Spitzenamt in diesem
Staat irgendwann mal bekleidet hat oder
ganz häufig an führender Stellung und
der genau das sagte sagt wir sind nicht
krisenfest und wir müssen unsere
Strukturen überdenken wir sind nicht in
der Lage ist hast du bei Corona gesehen
dann einfach mal zentral wirklich etwas
anzusagen und auch durchzusetzen und das
was in guten Zeiten ja etwas ist diese
er nennt das kuscheligen Föderalismus ja
was in guten Zeiten etwas war was uns
alle gut gefallen hat und gut gepasst
hat ja das ist aber wenn richtig Krise
ist nicht mehr die Struktur die Du
brauchst und da muss ich denken auch
übrigens
CDU Jens Spahn der in seinem letzten
Buch etwas irres beschreibt du erinnerst
dich die haben damals mitten in der
Pandemie deutsche aus Wuhan ausgeflogen
und dann war die Frage was passiert
jetzt mit diesen Leuten ja schleppen uns
da das Virus Virus ins Land das war zu
einem sehr frühen Zeitpunkt ich weiß
nicht ob du dich an diese episo so und
da wurden Leute eingeflogen stellte sich
tatsächlich raus zwei von den Wagen
glaube ich Corona positiv und dann haben
sie die kaserniert
wo du denkst ja gut okay die haben die
jetzt irgendwo mal untergebracht und
dann kuriert man das aus und danach
geht's auch wieder gut und er beschreibt
die Ohnmacht eines deutschen
Gesundheitsministers in diesem Buch die
Angst davor dass diese Leute einfach
aufstehen und nach Hause gehen und sagen
die weißt du was ihr könnt mich hier gar
nicht einsperren und das lasse ich mir
von euch auch nicht gefallen das ist
Freiheitsberaubung wir gehen jetzt
einfach Klammer auf und bringen dann das
Virus unter die Leute ist uns dann aber
auch egal das war die große Sorge weil
rein rechtlich sagt er hat mir
eigentlich wir hätten keine Handhabe
gehabt das finde ich interessant
bemerkenswert ist ja auch gut dass es so
ist ne ist natürlich ein großer Mann hat
solche Möglichkeiten im Rahmen der
Notstandsgesetze die unter anderem auch
zur solchen Präventionen mal eingeführt
wurden nicht als Hauptgrund aber der ist
einer der offiziellen Gründe jedenfalls
aber die Grenzen mal von eines
demokratischen Systems zu sehen ja ja
muss ich mal gucken was das größere Übel
und das kleinere Übel also ein
Einschnitte an der an dem Freiheit die
ich Liberalen Systemen vorzunehmen
könnten das deutlich größere Übel sein
richtig ja und das kommt wahrscheinlich
auf die größte der Gefahr drauf und
weißt du was Richard weißt du was ich
das allerbeste die Pointe daran was ich
so gut finde ist die Leute sind
freiwillig da geblieben man hat sie
davon überzeugt und hat den gesagt pass
auf das ist jetzt gerade mal notwendig
und siehe da sie haben es einfach
gemacht man muss es nicht groß anordnen
man musste sie nicht festhalten man
musste sie nicht irgendwo Fesseln
sondern sind einfach da geblieben haben
kommen wir am Ende genau da zu dem Fazit
ja also je mehr Menschen Einsicht haben
je mehr sie einsehen
ja sie je mehr Sie verstehen was sich
verändern muss in Ihrem eigenen
Interesse
umso besser werden wir diese ganz große
Herausforderung der gigantischen
Klimaveränderung mit all dem was im Volk
meistern können und ich glaube dass
diese Einsichtsfähigkeit dass die
relativ stark inzwischen entwickelt ist
und ich glaube dass die Politik mutiger
sein muss die einsichtigen ja aber
mitzunehmen zu sprechen anzusprechen und
auch zu sagen nein wir sind nicht
langsam wir machen und das ist ganz oben
und wir tun das auch und so weiter jetzt
muss man natürlich der Ehrlichkeit
halber sagen dass unsere Regierung im
letzten halben Jahr mit anderen
furchtbaren Problemen konfrontiert war
aber es ist unglaublich wichtig dass das
Klimathema in absehbarer Zeit wieder zum
wichtigsten Thema wird wir können uns
nicht leisten dieses Thema auf die lange
Bank zu schieben und ich erinnere mich
dass die Grünen ihren Wahlkampf damit
gemacht haben dass wir nun überhaupt
keine Zeit mehr haben und dass dies die
letzte Regierung ist die die Weichen
richtig stellen kann
also
Richard dank Dessert das war
ein spannender Austausch und wir hören
uns nächste Woche bis dann alles Gute
danke ciao
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF